what i want to do in this video is think
about how supply and or demand might
change based on changes in some factors
in the market and then think about what
that might do to the equilibrium price
and equilibrium quantity so let's say at
some period this is what the supply
curve looks like and this is what the
demand curve looks like and then all of
a sudden this thing happens a new
disease resistant apple is invented
what's likely to happen for the next
period
well a new disease resistant apple being
invented this is something that clearly
impacts the growers clearly impacts the
suppliers all of a sudden they'll have
fewer apples succumbing to disease and
so they will be able to produce more
apples so at any given price point at
any given price point this will shift
the quantity supplied up
so at any given price point it will
shift the quantity of apples supplied up
or you could say that the entire supply
curve
is shifted
is shifted to the right or supply goes
up and let me draw the entire curve and
obviously if now we have disease
resistant apples even our minimum price
to start producing apples is lower now
when we had the supply curve shift in
this way when it shifted to the right
what happens to the equilibrium price
well our old equilibrium price was right
over here
our new equilibrium price so this is the
old one and this is our new equilibrium
price we're assuming that the demand has
not changed at all so this is our new
equilibrium price so our new equilibrium
price is lower so the price
price went down and you don't have to
you could have probably reasoned through
that before taking an econ class but
this way at least you have some way to
think about it and think about how the
curves are changing
now let's think about this scenario
study so this is before so in all of
these examples this the graph is what
happened before the news came out or the
event came out so this is before and
then a study is released on how apples
prevent cancer so what is that likely to
do well no one wants cancer and so more
people are going to be eager to have
apples this will change customer
preferences they will prefer apples even
more when they're when they're at the
supermarket so this is clearly affecting
demand customer preferences and so at a
given price people will want to get
people will want a high they will demand
a higher quantity of apples the quantity
of apples demanded at a given price will
go up so the demand curve
will shift to the right or you could say
that demand would go up
so that's the new demand curve so here
demand goes up
demand
goes up and let me write over here in
this situation supply went up here
demand goes up and what happens to the
price
well this is our old equilibrium price
this is our new equilibrium price
the price clearly went up so the price
went up and actually over here let's
think about the quantity 2 in this first
situation this is our old equilibrium
quantity this is our new equilibrium
quantity quantity
quantity went up which makes sense you
have fewer apples dying price went down
more people want to buy them here price
went up and what happened to quantity
what happened to quantity quantity this
was our old equilibrium quantity this is
our new equilibrium quantity quantity
also went up
quantity also went up more people just
want to buy apples they don't want to
get cancer
now let's think about these scenarios
right over here the pair cider industry
launches an ad campaign and for the sake
of this let's assume that the same
growers who grow apples can also grow
pears that makes it interesting so you
have a couple of interesting things
by launching this advertising campaign
we'll assume it's a good advertising
campaign this clearly will make demand
demand go up for sorry it'll make demand
go up for cider for for pear cider
relative to apple cider most people when
they think of cider they think of apple
cider now the sudden pear cider comes
out it'll make demand for apple cider go
down so this is apple
apple cider
apple cider demand
will go down now if apple cider demand
goes down the apple cider producers are
going to demand fewer apples
so this is this is so this is going to
go mean that apple demand
apple demand will go down at any given
price point apple demand will go down
so apple demand the demand curve will
shift to the left i should say at any
given price point the quantity demanded
will go down and so the entire demand
curve the entire relationship will shift
to the left
we'll shift to the left
now that's not all that might happen
because if you think about it from the
suppliers point of view and i don't know
if this really is the case but let's
assume that the farmers who grow apples
can also grow pairs well they might say
well
why you know now that there's more
demand for pairs they're doing this
advertising campaign
i want to and probably the price of
pairs has gone up they might say well
i'm going to devote more my land to
pears and less of my land to apples and
so the supply of apples
the supply
of apples so apple supply i want to be
clear here that we're talking about
apple the apple supply might go down
so it will also shift to the left so
they're both shifting to the left
they're both shifting to the left now
what is likely to happen here so the
demand went down and the supply went
down they both shifted to the left well
here the way i drew it this was my
this was our old equilibrium price this
is our new equilibrium price it actually
looks the way that i drew it right over
here that it did not change the
equilibrium quantity definitely did
change so let's see this is our old
equilibrium quantity this is our new
equilibrium quantity this clearly the
quantity went down it was a bad day for
apples but the price didn't change
because at least in the example we
assumed that the farmers actually also
produced fewer apples it turns out you
could i could have drawn this in
multiple ways and actually let me draw
it in in different ways here so the
quantity definitely
so let's think about other scenarios let
me draw it slightly different let's say
that the supply goes down even more
dramatically so let's say the supply
shifts all the way
the supply shifts really far back now
what happened
well now our equilibrium price because
the the reduction in supply
was was kind of more extreme than the
the reduction in demand
now and it really depends on how the
curve shapes and all of that the main
thing is to reason through it or to
actually see what the actual results are
but in this situation all of a sudden
that the price the price went up but the
quantity definitely still went down so
in this case the one thing that you're
always going to be sure of is that the
quantity will go down but the price went
up because this effect the supply of the
supply went down much more than the
demand did and so the price went up now
i could have done another scenario i
could have done another scenario where
maybe the supply barely budged or maybe
the demand went down dramatically let me
dr do it where the supply barely budges
so maybe the supply it only gets shifted
a little bit to the left so maybe the
supply curve looks like this now all of
a sudden once again quantity definitely
goes down so in all of the scenarios the
quantity will go down but i've just done
three scenarios where the price could be
neutral the price could go up or the
price could go down so you actually
don't know
what is going to happen to the price
based on this you would actually have to
look at the actual curve and see what
the new equilibrium prices are
now let's look at this one the apple
pickers unionize demand and they demand
wage increases
so this is a this is an issue for the
suppliers so all of a sudden one of
their inputs one of their costs of
production which is labor has gone up so
if their cost of production has gone up
now at a given price point they are less
profitable less willing to produce
apples so at a given price point so
we're talking about the suppliers at a
given price point they will supply a
lower quantity they will supply a lower
quantity so this is going to
lower supply
this is going to lower supply
and when you lower supply
when you lower supply what's going to
happen
well your equilibrium quantity
your equilibrium quantity this was our
old one this is our new one equilibrium
quantity definitely goes down the
quantity went down and what happened to
the price we're assuming nothing changes
to the demand so this was our old
equilibrium price this is our new
equilibrium price it went up quantity
went down and price went up and i
encourage you to well one well i should
have told you this the beginning so you
should have tried to do these yourself
and then see what i had to say about
them but i encourage you to try this out
with different situations think of
situations yourself and even think about
different markets other than the apple
market